as we all know the real reason that
Dragonball Z has endured all these
decades is its timeless and challenging
depiction of class struggle in a world
that favors the uniquely privileged
sorry that should read breathless and
thrilling depiction of badass struggles
in a world that favors the insanely
powerful
stupid autocorrect
[Applause]
anyway a major element of Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot
is of course combat much like the show
battles are largely airborne affairs
with the dramatic push-pull dynamic
you'll have to master a variety of
offensive and defensive systems and
knowing when to alternate between the
two is an integral aspect of taking down
enemies with power levels exceeding 8999
amid these frenetic encounters Kakarot
faithfully recreates mid-battle
conversations this game is critical
combat moments
and iconic dramatic events which all
contributes to the feeling of being an
active participant in the legendary
anime
[Music]
feel me now fighting itself is
incredibly accessible for basic combat
there's a single button for up close
melee attacks one for ranged key blasts
and another for blocking dig down a
little deeper and you'll have ready
access to the full range of trademark
Dragonball fighting techniques the
shoulder buttons open up what the game
calls pallets for super attacks
transformations and support characters
super attacks are exactly what you
expect Kamehameha's meteor smashes
consecutive energy blasts all the good
stuff basically
it's likewise for transformations
initially you're limited to Goku's power
enhancing kaio-ken but as the story
progresses you can bet that the palette
expands to incorporate the various
stages of don't Super Saiyan and
possibly even fusions
the support palette is where things get
really interesting
allowing Goku to summon non-playable Z
warriors to leap into battle and lend a
hand support characters are divided into
offensive defensive and special types
the first two are fairly
self-explanatory while the latter keeps
your hit points and key levels topped up
while occasionally dishing out super
attacks or keeping you safe from enemy
ki blasts
[Music]
on the defensive side you can expend
valuable key by performing a burst to
knock the light enemy's attacking at
close quarters or surprise anyone
keeping their distance by closing the
gap with a vanish attack and if you're
feeling particularly skillful you can
attempt a last-minute dodge or step
maneuver to enter a slow-motion state
giving you a vital window to whale away
on your exposed probe successful step
maneuvers are just one of the actions
that caused your tension gauge to rise
once this meter is filled you can
trigger a surge which temporarily allows
you to chain and cancel out of moves
that typically allow for neither and
even lets you fire off multiple super
attacks for maximum devastation
observing yourself
join us next time for the third and
final video where we'll take a deeper
look at Dragon Ball Z Kakarot approach
to character progression and development
with a little training in the right
teacher that kid could be capable of
serious power